hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots oh no it's the worst thing get
ready to jam I'm sorry what what videos
is using the premier pre-installed
plugins to make to make this I know I
know that screen right there is a Adobe
Premiere pre-installed plugin it's the
breaking news intro yep there you go
that's right guys breaking news intro
002 it's time Drowning Pool is back what
yeah that's what drowning
pools this is Ms
smbs what get it media [__] you're
such a [__] cornball Tim you're s
this is Tim Po's new song you're such a
[__] cornball he's really not you're
not a funny guy did you see that picture
of somebody sharing him in [__] Capri
I was [__] howling at that picture
dude I why
does the year is 1967 and something
incredible happens to music Smokey Mike
and the god king unveiled their hit song
by the way Smokey Mike and the god king
is [__] Michael nolles and Jeremy
borings band name yeah cuz they're
friends CU you didn't want to die a
little bit
more I don't think I'm going to make it
through this
mer you'll be okay Budd I might quit the
show over this
let's
see are you looking up their their band
I got it oh yeah it's really good you
want to see you want to see the original
song before we play the cover cuz he's
doing a cover of this song aren't they
going to play C of it here or no maybe I
did this last night on my [__] and I
struggled to get through this no wait so
they're trying to do like a spinal tap
mockumentary type thing here yeah yeah
that's his bit no that's uh Christopher
guest's
bit
this is the original song daily wire
record so we can see what he what he's
doing why is and the god king not
capitalized because they're talking
about the god king I guess Trump and
they don't want to you know they're
still very religious okay yeah this is a
classic from our first album sing along
if you know the words this is a classic
from our only
album further proof that the daily wire
people never want to get into Political
stuff they all wanted to be musicians
and actors in Hollywood
yeah no somebody in my chat nailed it
last night they're all theater kids oh
yeah yeah they're all failed theater
[Music]
[Applause]
kids yeah this cornball shit's going to
win the culture War you [__] retards
I
hope Joe Biden wins again because of
this specifically N I don't blame him I
don't blame you charting in both 1967
and 1968 and spent 87 weeks at number
one needless to say America was hooked
and a legacy was born a legacy that
continues to this
day what inspired you to bring a song of
are you doing a behind the music thing
yeah he's doing a mockumentary that's
what I was saying this magnitude into
the world world I think it's no secret
that our band was effectively done after
Ian was caught mercilessly beating that
child what he's really funny guys oh my
God sorry guys I was muted I was
laughing so really is trying to be wacky
funny explain to me who finds this F you
could cost whatever you want I know Tim
because that's the thing every time I he
makes more money than you I don't care
about that right good that he's making
all the money good that he alls his
views but the real question I have is
who finds this [__] funny who is this
bought a bunch of meal buck even even
the premise it's not funny but you could
have executed it better like like if it
were me right if I were doing some I
would never do that I'd rather kill
myself but if I was doing some fake
mockumentary about me and Royce's band I
would have said something like obviously
we knew the band was over when Royce
went to prison on account of all that
stuff with the unpleasantness with the
kids yeah I wouldn't go beating that
child mercilessly like cuz you're trying
to be funny but like you're trying to be
like old like bang you over the head
funny where it's like all talk about
beating up kids where it would have been
funny if you just implied something
happen with kids that's funnier Tim you
leave it alone you go on of you know
that incident with those kids you go
wait what incident with the kids but I
was I was hoping there was some way the
viewer fill in the blank because they're
going to fill it in with the funniest
thing to them because they're funnier
than you Tim turn things around working
with my why do you think us hacks do
that do this all the time cuz our
audience is funnier than us we let them
draw their own conclusions no they
really are funnier than our audience is
probably the funniest audience that have
any
streamers not the women artist for
tredition of Phil leonti who used to
play avenge sevenfold tier garbage
[__] scene hardcore now now wants to
be extra manly metal man [__] it's
about how there's only two genders like
he's super edgy there is there something
we can do that's not how many [__] if
I cleaned your [__] car out right now
Phil how many [__] 16-year-olds
panties would I find yeah Bing and he
pointed out with all these greats like
the Beatles with Zepp got his little
cult in his compound why haven't any of
them committed mass suicide yet cuz he
can't really command a crowd in person
once you see his stature and overall
build it's always the cool Cults that
offer themselves uhhuh the Nexium many
banks some actresses you want to bang
both [__] from Smallville I don't
they didn't really destroy themselves
Department of Justice did that that's
true king mer waiting on their shipment
of 20 matching night
[Laughter]
of opportun DC or air walks no they
wouldn't there'd be some daily wire
shoot called like run
blacks run blacks run run blacks run
yeah modern versions that have not been
done properly now a lot of people have
covered Zeppelin of course but no one's
done a good modern I want you guys to
put that in your CW right there modern
modern and he was right and I think
that's when we realized if we get this
we get this right it could be huge so
Carter can can you tell me was it a
challenge to create a modern version of
such a Timeless classic no are you
[__] stupid wow you guys can't even
act like going to keep that take huh you
guys can't even act like it's one thing
that you're doing music which sucks
right but stop trying to be funny cuz
you're not funny is this a song
parody trying to do bad music trying to
do bad comedy you know right dare I say
it's almost as if Tim's wearing too many
hats oh yeah too many hats next question
okay well wow it's almost like the only
Talent this guy ever had was reading the
news yeah like to get into the area of
your crippling Rockstar Energy addiction
hey [__] you man we said that was off
limits oh my God he's bad oh this guy is
bad I am
uncomfortable the only thing worse than
the song is the
acting we haven't even got to the song
yet I know but I I know it's bad sound
to be good Hey where's my M&M's where's
Phil get Phil so you're doing the Eminem
you're doing the joke from way world the
Wayne's World joke you you you like
Wayne's World you watch Wayne's World
this is in
here and who's said who's had old lady
in that picture L
Luma now that's a Wings world
reference hey
mer what
you did I'm
sorry modern the weekend from
2014 oh no it sounds just like the
[Applause]
weekend oh my God does anything is
anything Tim ever done like it's the
weekend or yeah like he doesn't have
anything
original Tim the weekday
cool dude this is this is the same song
yeah look what you wait till you hear
his [__] vocals oh my God you you're
not even prepared for this I'm a
[__]
[__] look what you
done I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out no
no no we're here both of you come back
both of you put those [__] headphones
back on honestly I get back the
I you know I need to do this I'm going
to call skin and hush see if they need a
DJ I don't need this as long I mean they
I don't need this they won't give me
Fridays and Saturday nights but I could
maybe get a Thursday or Wednesday and
the first song you play this one
mhm how does this like you got no
friends Tim all you have as people that
get a paycheck from you yeah yeah he
you're right that's a good point no
friends at all nobody tells tells him
anything yeah like like with our group
of friends any one of us would just be
like bro this [__] sucks like we're
funny doing this and and you know what
the other one would say thanks bro
thanks for saving me from myself
seriously I'm I'm glad yeah probably is
bad can you believe I almost released
that cat is gay yeah there you go that's
fair you say
goodbye bro I I was using every excuse I
could to go on tangents while I was
trying to cover this hang on hang on
he's digitizing his voice wait for the
[Music]
glitches what is
this you guys don't
understand you fast life can um Can Tim
hear his own voice no that's all he
listens to what are you talking about
how does he think he has a good voice
like I I'm saying object like I know we
[__] on Tim pool whatever but I mean it
could be an artist I like right like
like if Alkaline Trio came out with a
new album and Matt skeba sounded like
this I'd go is he okay you know like did
he have did he have some kind of vocal
cord surgery like bro if this is what
you sound like now maybe you shouldn't
be singing these songs
anymore he really thinks who the [__] he
is
Tim I know you watch these cuz I know
you watch anything that pops up on
YouTube with your name I'm very aware of
that I know you would want to mention us
because I understand that that would
just put more people to how [__] how
much we roast you and stuff but honestly
and I'm saying this with without the
joke or anything but you need to
stop you you need to stop look I don't
care if you want to do your culture
commentary stuff and your middle of the
road fence riding and and your [__]
investigative reports about Eliza blue
where you cover up for her you could do
whatever you want that that's that's
your [__] don't sell your food
buckets I really don't care you know
censor Alex Jones episode when he was on
cuz you're a [__] you could do all
those things but please stop making this
music because the problem is we're gonna
have to listen to it and now my day is
ruined my day is ruined because Tim pool
couldn't stick to [__] having people
on that he [__] at come on Tim this
song has
47,000 up votes read comment 3.7 million
views is that a core from Portal it is
he also throws did they steal valve
assets that is that that's that's what's
that's what's his face you're right
pessy all of this is stolen assets a
second they flash up the The Laughing
Man symbol from Ghost in the Shell is
that GLaDOS from from really it's like
one of the personality
cores it's the one in the second one
that was voiced by Steven Merchant yeah
well there's also like a few other was
like the red one I'm I'm not as big of a
nerd as you are just this Portal's good
enough enough these people aren't going
to get it these people are very dumb
that listen to the show they're not
going to get it so good mov game
[Music]
whatever they've got so many straps guys
they're in the future oh that's how you
can tell they're in the future oh God
somebody wrote and I quote it's better
than the weekend I I'm I'm I'm I I don't
want to do this that had to be a joke
right there's no way I don't want 47,000
I don't want to do this anymore how can
it be better than the weekend when the
weekend literally invented this song
it's the weekend's song Tell Rumble our
contract's an all in void I don't want
do I'm going back to the clubs can't do
this anymore can't compete with these
people n Rumble just put in that plaque
in here that said remember you're here
forever you're here forever good and M
has it that says do it for her and it
just pictures of Blair
white somebody make that do the switch
the py pictures white do it for
[Music]
her here's a great comment hey is it
weird that I liked that good job guys if
you're asking yourself that that's
literally your brain fighting
you right this is so bad you have inner
turmoil yeah that's no legit though
right there's two wolves inside you when
one of them thinks Tim pool
sucks that's what they
calling look [__] oh my God by the way
these these YouTube views and because
you posted on Tim his timcast music
thing right 3.7 million views
right it it is it is such a lie that
these people live in where if they think
YouTube views like like someone just
point out in the chat this music is
going to be playing in the [__] clubs
it's not going to be playing on cars can
I find it on Touch Tunes oh my if they
did I would pick it 40 times at the my
bar and would not stop playing it it
would be the only song playing at my bar
a great way to make friends I don't care
about the people in my bar together
again hold on M M M come on Michael dods
uh says this on ironically slaps in the
comments wanted level oh like GTA that's
cool remember that he said that he that
that he he couldn't play the new GTA
because he couldn't believe that a woman
would be able to beat him up I know
women in my family they could beat you
up yeah know for real
so the last three women I've had sex
with could kick the [__] out of you Tim
well two of them were dudes that's true
but they used to be guys hey trans women
or women that's the rules thank you I'll
make the rules I'm not gay anymore
apparently look I don't make the rules
the Jews do right so hey you know take
it up with
[Music]
that oh my God all right all right Ty
typical Tim fool fan can I this is the
smart people that listen to Timol I
would have been a freshman in high
school I don't remember this song ever
and if you report it was a number one on
the charts for 87 weeks straight no that
is a lie records indicate that's life by
Frank Sinatra made the number one spot
for two weeks did this guy really think
it was a real
song are you [__]
[Laughter]
serious I feel better now you know what
we're never going to have an audience
this biggest tin pools but a fat [__]
F I'm fine with that I don't care if we
don't have an audience of biggest tin
pool because if being a biggest tin pool
means having to do this and having to
also make your show as PG-13 as possible
to stay on YouTube it ain't worth it to
me you
know how is this any less gay than
wearing a dress no wearing a dress takes
more balls because you could see
them Mario Kart Mario Kart now right the
banana peel Mario Kart M get
it cuz Tim's a big gamer you're just
throwing G half that word you're just
throwing things into
[Music]
this oh here we go uh uh here's another
one from subie Ninja uh the beginning
was
hilarious huh look look look at Tim
trying to convince humans that he
experiences emotion right there and that
still frame hey guys I think I've been
having feelings hey Ian I think I've
been having feelings you not been having
feelings okay here's a good comment are
you sure the children didn't beat Ian up
yeah that guy rules hey how about a uh
Tim poool try to go real beer
challenge search for you again I've been
alone for so long
is is this song about how much he wants
to [__] his bro I don't know but that's
a bad beard buddy don't grow one if you
can't please he keeps s he keep singing
I've been alone I've been alone and it's
showing his friend's face up close and
I'm like Tim are you uh yeah here's
another comment from uh Roger Wilco Ms
smbs H oh I get
it i'
[Music]
been what is this
garbage oh it's the metro station but
gayer the metro station that's a very
yeah quite
[Music]
gayer is a good comment this [__] is gay
as hell thank you thank
you a no we
my oh look there's the guy that's Phil
leonti he's so metal now guys hey
remember when you were making real money
in a real
band and you have respect of your peers
honestly I would rather get the vax than
hang out with Tim P I would have just
gotten the vax and been like I'm still
on The Offspring guys and all this is
synth by the way there's no even real
band playing right now this is all
synth
[Music]
o oh by the way hey get right get ready
get ready this is a fun one you could
tell the Tim pool fans because we're on
the front page right now in the chat a
Josephine 777 ABC great name that you
just made up right now by the way you
guys are not that funny either uh excuse
me we're [__] hilarious we're one of
the funniest shows around have you heard
our anti- zist juvenile rap that alone
is worth the price of AD are you [__]
kidding me it's one of the funny things
we
did and it doesn't matter for funny
because Rumble keeps paying us mhm so
that's how you like them app how do you
like that yeah it's two words downside
guarantee hey you want me to it's a
whole lot of downside uh you could
guarantee
that
[__] hey hey you guys want to hear
some tough guy Phil leonti lyrics fine
no this is from the hit Whispers I hear
you from All That Remains a good it may
seem At Last Days passing mean nothing
but the Sun that sets cause only pain
violence in words like slashes wound
deeply love is not when you feel only
pain oh you know what I he found out
apparently All That Remains is being in
a [__] shitty YouTube ban with the
fence sitting homo
yeah yeah for Phil Leon All That Remains
is past
royalties Ro you have to get people
playing your music to get royalty a good
point you're
[Music]
seriously I don't understand what's the
ice cream have to do with anything also
that's a pretty shitty ice cream on
sprinkles and a cherry it is it's
probably Briar or some
[__]
you're not cool stop you're not cool oh
yeah well if he's not cool then how did
he do this he's not
cool pretty cool that was so cool pretty
you know how many babes must love him
none zero babes bro all the babes so
many babes all right how many of them
get a 1099 from timcast iro all the
babes broo bro he's [__] all the babes
that he's [__] them over again he's
on new babe plus yeah he is oh wow hey
hey merch hey merch all babes yeah
that's right actually his place is all
grip tape it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
all what is
this um the losing of the culture war in
a video I mean I don't
know Tim P playing with green screens in
his garage I don't know I think Tim P's
kind kind of cute Blair white 2023 Blair
white is the only one well cuz they're
both Asian dudes oh yeah they probably
appreciate each other yeah they do they
do I don't care if we never get invited
on your stupid show
[Music]
dumbass
you they're not both Asian men they're
both Haas is in like [__] Temple is a
haa and B white happens to [__]
disappoint her father I was going to say
happens to to have a
penis how does how do his voice is being
processed through so many
layers and it still sounds terrible
spooki says as a female this makes me
very uncomfortable he rides around with
his boyfriend and gets us sunde I quit
oh my God the videoos him riding around
with his boyfriend ice getting ice cream
with a guy [__] hey pess you want to
ride you want to ride around and get
some menes together maybe some froo like
[__] men yes
okay I was say m just said that his
voice is very processed you could say
his voice is the Blair white of
singing transitioned but into something
equally awful
mhm [__] [__] is so autotuned it
should have a melodine watermark on it
it really is
[Music]
bro [__] like sounds like te pains me
to listen to
this funnyest show on Rumble Josephine
you [__] [__] [__] how's that sound
that's what you want to hear on Tim pool
cuz of
[Music]
YouTube and as one of our oh good
friends once said saraj once said let
Tim Cook like days BL it's night ain't
no storm we care where the mother we
what is
this you're not
[Music]
cool are you going to [__] are they
going to are they looking at each
other's
dicks what so funny you guys got ice
cream what was the joke I have no clue
man well the [__] joke no we're we're
the [__] joke actually that's what it
is the joke's on us we're the
[__] jokes on D guess the jokes on
D is this just 20 seconds of him eating
ice cream mhm think so the other day I
was sitting on a park bench and a kid
just wrote gash me I'm filth in my
vagina Jes on why didn't they pick a why
didn't they pick a font at the end there
with to be continued why didn't they
pick a font where the question mark
match the rest of the letters that bugs
the living [__] out of me and I I hate
they got a font that didn't come with
punctuation
damn
it that's not even a question mark
That's Just the door Dash
[Laughter]
logo